[Music]
is
love it
just kidding hi john langler this is
politics now
the number one politics show on eight
news now
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
i believe that that mining has to pay it
its fair share mining pays every tax
every other business pays
plus an industry specific tax
when you're shooting
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
i believe that that mining has to pay it
its fair share mining pays every tax
every other business pays
plus an industry specific tax tonight on
politics now
mining in the hot seat we hear from both
sides as the legislature considers
raising taxes on the mining industry
saying good night to daylight saving
time the latest effort by lawmakers to
keep us on pacific standard time
all year round and we continue our
interviews with new members of the
legislature
we'll speak with democratic
assemblywoman elaine marzola
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us on
politics now i'm john langler up in
carson city
lawmakers are trying to fill the state
budget during the legislative session
with opportunities to get more money
into state coffers few and far between
legislators are honing in on one of the
few options they actually have
and the main one is the net proceeds tax
it's
specific to the mining industry but
nevada's constitution puts a cap on how
much can be charged there
before mining can be asked to pay more
that cap
has to be removed and that process has
to pass the legislature twice and then
have a general election ballot
well it already went through the last
summer special session
and if lawmakers pass it again in this
session this is going to go to a public
vote
so let's dig into both sides of the
so-called mining tax
first we spoke with the president of the
nevada mining association tyree gray
he's relatively new in that job and he's
also the first african-american to hold
it
is there any way you think that this
legislative session ends without
additional taxes being imposed or um
as you say sort of more burdens i guess
put on your industry
well i would say that what we're looking
at right now
is to have good conversation i don't i
can't read the tea leaves unfortunately
over what will happen over the next 90
days a session if i could i would
definitely tell you that
but i will tell you that the mining
industry has been at the table to talk
about revenue increases and we've always
been at the table to talk about revenue
increases
we supported the 2015 revenue increase
in the commerce tax
we've come we've continuously supported
revenue increases throughout
the state's history so it's not uncommon
for the mining industry to be at the
table to talk about
revenue increases but again we do have
to look at broad-based solutions
industry-specific taxes are never good
tax policy they place
a burden on a particular industry that
then could have negative downfall
and what we've seen is you know by the
estimations that some of these tax
passages could lead to
um upwards to 30 percent contraction um
in the mining industry
and you know there are 37 000 families
uh throughout nevada
that depend on the mining sector in
order to have their livelihood so when
you look at 30 percent
um it's really difficult to say to 12
000 people that hey you might be
being shifted from a 95 000 a year job
onto um the the state social safety net
and what does that actually
do um to those those people what does
that actually do to those communities
because
the one thing that we're losing and
particularly when you talk about agr1
and sjr one
is that it's not a not necessarily the
impact of the mining industry it's
really the impact of the county
we're removing tax revenue from counties
that then the counties will
presumably have to go back to the state
and try to recruit
why are you one of the main ways that
they think they can raise more revenue
if things are going so great what's
wrong with the way it is now
well you know i think that there's
always a need to to take a look at
our current systems and you know and
really appraise what our tax mechanisms
are again
i think it's within the legislature's
preview or purview i should say to look
at
the tax scheme um that exists in nevada
and i think what's really important is
that nevada's taxes were always based on
property tax
um again we've added taxes along the way
and we've kind of you know
added tax here at attacks there but
really a comprehensive study of taxes in
nevada i don't think has really been
undertaken in a number of years and i
think if not for
the pandemic i think you know the
governor had signaled that 2021 would be
a time where we would talk about taxes
not just on a particular industry but
all the way around i mean i think it's
important to recognize that nevada
currently abates
1 billion 1.2 billion dollars in
property tax every year
and so that's an astronomical figure
that would you mean be able to be able
to use
be used toward um education and health
care funding and you know continuing to
diversify our economy so i think you
know we really have to look at
the whole tax system and not just the
tax system on a particular industry
mining pays every tax every other
business pays
plus an industry specific tax it's
important to recognize that so you know
if the four
four people go to the go to uh go have a
slice of pizza
and it's two dollars a person we put our
two dollars on the table just like
everybody else does and then we have an
additional tax that we pay
on top of that two dollars to share that
pie
meanwhile nevada democratic activists
say mining is not paying its fair share
so how much should they pay the i-team's
david charn spoke with the executive
director of battleborn progress and at
magnus
it is a large nevada industry so is this
something that
that is realistic uh the
the mining taxes absolutely realistic
and it shouldn't matter where you live
in the state of nevada i know the mining
companies are very much
trying to pit rural nevadans against
uh you know southern nevadans and
northern nevadans who live in urban
communities but
this is a nevada issue period it doesn't
matter where you live i was born and
raised in nevada i'm a second generation
nevadan
and i believe that that mining has to
pay
its fair share they never have and you
know you see
the way mining is taxed in other states
around the west
and they are paying their fair share but
in the state of nevada
they were written into our constitution
in 1864 and have been there ever since
and so
they're paying some small fees and other
things but they are not paying
full taxes for the minerals that they
extract out of the ground
i think the best one is ajr1 assembly
joint resolution one
the the what we're talking about is the
constitutionally capped rate of five
percent on net proceeds
moving that to 7.75 on gross proceeds
bringing an additional
507 or 543 million dollars a year
that would be huge for our state and
that would fill a lot of those
gaps that we're seeing not just during
the pandemic but
historically that we've seen you know
help us get our education system fully
funded
help us move things forward around our
mental health system i mean
543 million dollars is not chump change
that is a huge amount of money
why still do it if it's not going to
cover the shortfall that they're so
worried about
well the thing is is that this is
something that's needed to be done for a
long time and when the economy is good
nobody's running around saying oh we
need to update our revenue
streams and our revenue systems even
though we desperately need to do those
things even when the economy is
good and so for us it's really important
because
if we're not willing to have this
conversation now when
our state is literally desperate for
money
then when are we going to have this
conversation we have not revisited in
a real way our revenue streams and our
revenue system since 1961 in this state
now as magnus said there are actually
three separate resolutions
that would deal with raising mining
taxes the main one as she said is
assembly joint resolution one ajr1
as from the special session over the
summer none of them have scheduled a
vote yet
here are some other bills that were
introduced this week one would protect
schools from coronavirus related
lawsuits assembly bill 159 was
introduced by republican assemblyman ira
hansen
it would prevent personal injury or
wrongful death lawsuits against public
schools because of covet exposure
as long as the health guidelines are
being followed at the time if passed
it would kick in as soon as the state of
emergency is lifted in nevada
another new bill requires insurance
companies to cover the treatment of
gender dysphoria
senate bill 139 is sponsored by
democratic state senators melanie
shibley and dallas harris
the coverage would include things like
hormone therapy treatment
or gender reassignment surgery it would
also require private insurance companies
and medicaid to cover
treatments for other sexual disorders a
bill to do away with daylight saving
time is once again up in the state
legislature
daylight saving time is of course
federal law
the bill asks governor sisilak to ask
president biden to get rid of the time
change
senate bill 153 would only take effect
though if california does the same
change and that would keep us
both both states on pacific standard
time now this might sound familiar
lawmakers passed a similar resolution
back in 2015
however that resolution asked to keep
nevada on the same time as
arizona which would be one hour ahead of
california in the winter time
again this one would put us in step with
california
don't change your clocks just yet next
on politics now
representing their my main objective is
just to
work really hard to make a difference
for hard-working families
our conversation with new members of the
hispanic legislative
caucus continues with assemblywoman
elaine marzola
and you may have heard the term latinx
before
what does it mean are people using it
we're going to explore latin next next
on politics now
welcome back to politics now
democratic assemblywoman elaine marzola
represents district 21.
that seat covers neighborhoods in the
southeast valley mainly around silverado
ranch
marzola is a brazilian-born attorney one
of three new lawmakers joining the
hispanic legislative caucus
christian cazares explored her
legislative priorities
representation i mean very important how
do you feel about that
i think we're getting better i think
that uh
you know we still need some work uh
but definitely what you see in the
legislature
today versus 10 years ago in the latin
you know
with hispanic or just latin
representation period is very different
so i think we're definitely moving in
the right direction
okay and then uh my next question is um
are you working on any bills are you you
know what's what's your game plan here
kind of you know moving forward
my main objective it is my first session
uh
you know i've never been in this
position before but my main focus
my main objective is just to
work really hard to make a difference
for hard-working families
you know our kids are need to get back
to school they need to get back to
school safely of course but i think
that's really really important
and then another issue that is dear to
my heart
um also small businesses we need to help
them get them off their feet
get them the assistance that they need
so that they can either reopen or stay
open hire
people back that you know maybe they've
had to let go
during the pandemic and also affordable
health care
is really really important anything that
you've kind of uh
had the opportunity to kind of get the
ball rolling on any of these four items
not yet i do have a uh affordable
housing
bdr that i am working on language is not
um has not been finalized yet but it
will give
you know tools that we need
in order to provide affordable housing
funding
which which i'm sure you know affordable
housing is a huge issue here
whether in the south or in the north
indeed it is that was our christian
cazares interviewing assemblywoman
elaine marzola
you can check out our interviews with
all three new members of the hispanic
legislative caucus
over at eightnewsnow.com now you may
have heard
activists or politicians using the term
recently latin
x now the x replaces the masculine
latino or the feminine latina makes the
term gender neutral
as our hector mejia explains while the
movement to use latinx is gaining
traction around the world
very few hispanics here in the u.s
actually use it
i actually had to look it up i was also
kind of like whoa
why is there an x at the end the greater
population remains divided
and so the x is the start but it's not
enough
the pew research center points out the
gender neutral term
latinx is being embraced by celebrities
politicians and grassroots organizations
latinx folks are going to be the biggest
voting block in this election in 2020
apple even created a latinx heritage
month section with videos playlists and
other content
not only does our community still
struggle with internalized racism
it also struggles with internalized
queer phobia and sexism
a study by the pew research center also
found out
that most latino adults 76 percent have
not even heard of the term
while one in four u.s hispanics have
only three percent actually use it
dr erica abbad is a professor at unlv
where more than 25 percent of the
students are latino or latinx
student life often uses it to promote
their events
frederick aldama has written more than
45 books on the topic
plus a documentary on latinx superheroes
we're sort of in
in a movement as opposed to a series of
moments of representation
in the media the ohio state university
professor says
what's important here is that the
community is the one behind the movement
we've all been told by the census by the
government
you know how to self-identify and how to
call ourselves we don't need to be
prescriptive about it like telling
people you need to be
self-identifying latinx this is really
about giving us options the transgender
non-binary community experiences too
much violence on a daily basis
i don't want to see that anymore and
sometimes it's
and something as simple as recognizing
their gender pronouns
their name and the terms they prefer
makes a world of difference hector mejia
8 news now
now that pew research center study that
we referenced there it found young
hispanic women
are among the most likely to use the
term latinx we have a link to the study
and more information over at eight
newsnow dot com
next on politics now ready to run
senator catherine cortez-masto announces
her re-election campaign
the case she's making and how much money
her campaign is going to be starting
with we have that coming up
plus washington dc bureau correspondent
alexander limon
we'll talk about the nominee for the
secretary of the interior
and her ties to the west it's 8 news now
you're watching politics now
this week nevada democratic senator
catherine cortez masto announced that
she is running for reelection
just this last year i was able to pass
13 pieces of legislation
and i did that because i reached across
the aisle and worked with a republican
colleague
and we got it done in a republican
administration
so that that tells you kind of gives you
an idea the focus here is is to really
solving problems for people
in my state and that that's not going to
change
senator cortez mastos up for reelection
in 2022
she's the first latina to serve in the
u.s senate cortes masto chairs a
subcommittee on the senate energy and
natural resources committee
and that committee oversees public lands
in the mining industry
cortes masto's fec filings show her
campaign started 2021 with more than 3
million dollars on hand in cash
so far no republicans have formally
declared that they're going to run
against her
another nevada democrat has snagged some
key assignments in congress we're
talking about representative dina titus
she is the longest serving member of the
nevada delegation in washington
she'll chair the gaming caucus and the
tourism caucus
the travel and tourism caucus has about
a hundred members the gaming caucus
about 30. president joe biden's cabinet
nominees are now going through their
confirmation hearings in washington
one position with a big influence here
in nevada is is the secretary of the
interior
new mexico congresswoman deb holland
started her confirmation hearings for
that position this week
the government agencies under the
department of interior control public
lands which as you know make up more
than 85 percent of nevada
new mexico congresswoman deb holland is
an historic nominee for secretary of the
interior she's a native american woman
but
her confirmation hearings have been
pretty tough one of the tougher ones for
the biden administration we're joined by
alexander limon to talk about
some of the hang-ups that senators had
about congresswoman holland
what were some of the biggest concerns
well i would say that the biggest
concern about congresswoman deb
holland's nomination for secretary of
interior
is her stance on fossil fuel production
and there was a lot of focus
on whether she as secretary of interior
and president biden
would move to permanently ban oil and
gas drilling and exploration
on federal lands and waters and also on
the issue
of fracking and in fact some republican
senators
really came out to speak strongly
against holland's nomination
uh calling her a radical you know she is
one of the most progressive members of
congress
they also tried to say that she's out of
touch with the west
that's a little bit of a hard you know
thing to prove or to say
seeing as she is a congresswoman from
new mexico
but still they really tried to fight her
nomination because again of the issue
of fossil fuels but congresswoman
holland actually did
you know pretty well during her
confirmation hearings fielding these
questions
and she actually told senators that she
thinks and she understands that fossil
fuels do
have to be a part of the country's
energy strategy
at least for the foreseeable future
western states had
quite a bit of conflict with the
interior department under
the trump administration and ryan zinke
who used to run it
during that administration a lot of
times the questions that are asked in
these hearings kind of reflect
what's important to the states what's
important to what would
happen in the new department of the
interior administration
i think we get a fair idea of this but
what kind of a direction do you expect
or
will we expect to see uh in a in a
holland
led interior department the reason that
this is such a historic nomination is
the fact that she is a native american
woman
and so one of the things that i think
people say was lacking
not just during the trump administration
but kind of historically has been
lacking in the department of interior is
a strong representation
of native american tribes and of course
that was alexander limon from washington
d.c
a date for the vote on congresswoman
holland
has not yet been scheduled nevada's
congressional delegation has a new
proposal in washington that could have
some big benefits here in las vegas
it comes from senator cortez masto and
congressman stephen horsford
and it encourages the hospitality injury
industry rather
to re-hire workers and bring convention
business back